out again a lot of rain would be a good
thing as long as it doesn't present
problems on the roads you know so a
little rain today is kind of what we're
looking for don't you love this shot
this is our camera sits up on top of
Black Mountain which is about 5 000 feet
at the South End of the valley and so
we're looking to the center of town
which you can kind of see the strip here
we've got clouds down here right in the
foreground up around 5000 feet and a
little bit lower and then clouds all
around us this is the beginnings of that
next Pacific storm which is already
hitting California this morning with
some pretty good rain on the coast and
even moving Inland temperatures mostly
in the 40s for us 39 at Red Rock 20's up
there at Kyle Canyon looking for rain
and snow in the mountains today with a
Chance of some Valley showers mainly
this afternoon but this is just going to
be the preview day tomorrow's the really
big show we've got 40s Mesquite Boulder
City mid 50s for Laughlin freezing in
Indian Springs 42 in Pahrump and around
freezing up there in Caliente all right
let's run the futurecast today but
through the afternoon some light showers
around at best but tomorrow is where
we're expecting the heavier rain
steadier rainfall and the heavier snow
in the mountains and it looks like now
it could be significant snow for our
local mountains and that's fantastic
news Thursday will be the busiest day
then the system should be moving out by
Friday it's all thanks to the
atmospheric River now the low itself is
really aimed up at the Pacific Northwest
and Northern California but there will
be enough energy at the base of that low
to bring in enough rain for the valley
though we could see maybe a quarter of
an inch and maybe up to a foot or more
of snow in the higher elevation so
already starting to see the rain move
into California our winter storm watches
have been elevated to and upgraded to
winter storm warnings those start at 4
a.m that's a wind advisory that we're
looking at that time but 4 a.m Thursday
morning to 4 a.m Friday morning and
again six thousand to seven thousand
feet will be the snow level so warmer
air kind of pushing those snow levels up
a little bit higher but again winter
winter weather driving conditions in the
mountains for sure in those elevations
and higher 53 today cloudy this morning
and then we're looking for that slight
chance of showers in the afternoon a mix
of rain and snow developing through the
day up in the mountains 34 for Kyle
Canyon with some upper 20's up at Lee
Canyon showers likely through the day
tomorrow starting before Daybreak into
tomorrow evening again maybe a quarter
of an inch of rain for the lower
elevations AT Systems gone by Friday
with sunny skies a few lingering clouds
next week more chances for rain as more
systems move in out of the Pacific Boy
2023 has been fantastic for rain and
snow